[music]
>> There was a time when I thought
that
I'm going to let you give me the skill.
So, I was not very bothered about the
life partner. Life partner, whatever she
is.
Maximum 2 months.
I can convince anyone. That was my
thinking, which is totally wrong.
Anyone, no [clears throat] problem.
Allah has given that skill. So, to
convince anyone is easy. So, that was my
thinking. That's fine. I want a life
partner, but whatever she is
I will get on the track. But
alhamdulillah, when the time of marriage
came
Allah gave me wisdom.
And that's the time we thought, "No, I
have to get a daya
as a life partner if I want to become a
successful day."
The life partner
is called as the better half. Not only
in English, in most of the languages.
In Hindi, we say ardhangini. Means half
my body.
And most of the languages if you convert
the idiom for the wife is better half or
half.
And alhamdulillah, I could not find
anyone in
Bombay. Not that I interviewed anyone.
It was my sister who did the interview.
So, she only passed one.
In interview only no one passed. So,
there's no question of
me meeting anyone.
So, only one she passed.
That was out of Bombay from Pune. And
alhamdulillah,
Allah has
blessed me
that the family support was very
important. First of the parents,
then of my brother. I'll come to it
later on in some other session. Then of
the wife, we shall discuss later on.
Going ahead with the thought of doing a
dawa training program, when we went
through notes of various dawa training
programs, I thought more it was of
written work. This is there Read this
thing. Read these verses. That's it.
And I met many
doers who had done training programs,
but interacting with them
didn't really
feel that they had specialized in the
way.
So, alhamdulillah, after that when I met
Sheikh Deedat,
he was very disappointed.
He told me,
"I have a different view
regarding days."
He said, "What, uncle?" I used to call
him uncle and he used to call me son.
I remember when he called me
the second time when I went. First time
I went was in 1988
to South Africa.
Second time I went was in
1994.
And Farik, my son, was 2 and 1/2 months.
2 and 1/2 months he was there at the
photograph with Sheikh Deedat.
Alhamdulillah. And that time, the first
lecture I gave abroad outside India
was in front of Sheikh Deedat.
And that is the time to encourage me he
gave me the title Deedat Plus.
I didn't agree with it.
It is his kindness and his
humbleness that he called me Deedat
Plus. From that
it went on.
And I remember the first
talk after South Africa
was in Saudi Arabia in 1996.
And Sheikh Deedat told me, "Son, when
you go to Saudi,
don't expect the crowd you get in
Bombay." I remember Bombay the first
time we did a public lecture. This was
in the organization. The first time we
did a public talk was in 1994.
I got married in 1993.
In 1994, before that I had the first
debate of my life.
First debate of my life.
While doing this debate,
we will do it in the debating section,
inshallah. Let's not spend time here.
First lecture I gave, we were expecting
about maybe 200 people to come. And we
had an Indian Merchant Chamber, and
masha Allah, 400 people turned up. The
next lecture 1,000, then 2,000. Kept on
increasing. In 1995, at that time it was
4,000, masha Allah. 4,000 people coming.
Great, alhamdulillah.
The first trip I made abroad after South
Africa,
an official trip only for lectures.
In Saudi Arabia, Sheikh Deedat told me
that, "Son, Saudi Arabia is a different
country.
You can't give lectures openly. You may
give in hospitals and education. You
don't expect the crowd in Bombay. You
may get four people, 10 people, 20
people. Don't worry."
So, I was mentally prepared that 20-25
people I'm going to address in Saudi
Arabia.
The first talk I gave in Jeddah,
alhamdulillah, more than 1,000 people
turned up.
And I'm wondering how did 1,000 people
turn up there? Then I realized one of my
fans circulated that cassette is the
Quran God word.
And that's how people came.
That's how the journey started.
And when I discussed with Sheikh Deedat
in the early '90s,
he told me, "Son,
these dawa training programs are
useless." I said, "Why, uncle?"
He said,
"That, son, who trained you? Did I train
you?"
I said, "No."
"Allah chose you. Who trained me?"
"Allah chose me."
Days are chosen by Allah.
What do you train?
It's waste of time. And he was right in
many ways. I agree with him.
That he wouldn't train me.
And being so direct, he believed in
being attacking direct. So, "Did I train
you?"
I said, "No, uncle."
"It's your passion.
It's Allah chose you." I said, "Yes."
"So, waste of time." I was taken aback.
Why is he saying this?
He said, "I spent 2 months time
in the dawa training program 1988. Spent
phenomenal amount of money.
What is the use?"
He had a bad experience.
And I don't blame him.
He believed in creating doers and
leaving no stone unturned. 2 months
training program, everything free
including ticket and everything.
2 months stay.
And then I saw the video.
He condensed his 2 months training
program into nine videos of 1 hour each.
Nine videos of
1 hour each means 9 hours. 2 months
program.
I don't remember whether 5 days
a week or 6 days a week.
Whatever it was, 2 months,
irrespective whether it's 5 days or 6
days,
he edited it and got 9 hours.
And whenever I got new tapes, I used to
watch it. And I watched the 9 hours.
After watching the 9 hours,
I agreed with Sheikh Deedat.
"Uncle, what you say is right. If this
is the product
after the training program,
I agree with you, uncle.
I won't give you the details. I don't
want to
demotivate anyone.
But this was in 1988.
And later on Sheikh Deedat, he changed
his style.
If you have seen his tapes, he started
doing a 2-hour training program called
as combat kit.
Inshallah, we'll be doing that 2 hours
here also.
He said, "Now, I've changed. I go to a
city, 2 hours, फटाफट
whether they get inspired or not, I
train 20 people, 30 people, 50 people.
Even if two gets, no problem.
Anyone with a passion picks up and
learns. Why waste 2 months?"
And a person who wants to excel should
always learn, as I told you earlier on
the first day yesterday,
that intelligent person learns from
other people's mistakes.
Sheikh Deedat, may Allah inshallah grant
him Jannah. May Allah give him Jazak
Allah Khair for all that he has done. He
has inspired thousands of youngsters
throughout the world including myself.
And I can off
the Islamic world in the field of dawa.
Saying this,
it was really
very demotivating.
But I agreed with him.
And when the time came, maybe 10 years
after that in 1998, after he
had the stroke in 1996,
I thought of let's
do a 1-day training program.
It was in 1997 or 1998. 1997, I believe.
The first time we did a 1-day dawa
training program.
And before doing that, we checked up
with the other organizations. And I have
a passion of visiting different
countries, USA, went to UK, South
Africa, Malaysia, Australia, Singapore.
Variety. Which is the best organization?
okay this. Which is the best in
Singapore?
It is Darul Arqam. Okay, go there. Okay,
met Ridwan who? Met Arif Sultan. In
Malaysia, which is the okay this
organization. In Saudi Arabia, okay
Dawah Center. Went to ICNA, went to
ISNA, and various organizations. May
Allah give jazak khair to all these
organizations for whatever good work
they've done for the cause of Islam and
for the Muslim ummah.
Alhamdulillah.
Then we thought okay, let's do something
different. When we had the one day Dawah
training program,
it was planned for 8 hours, it went and
extended for as usual to
9-10 hours.
Then we found that it was quite
successful, then we decided to have
a longer version
of 15 days.
That was in 19
or 97.
First time we had the first phase, and
we involved most of the core group
members who we felt were du'at from
Bombay. We took the interview, but I
said okay, fine.
Before doing the course,
I believe that entry should not be easy.
I had my own policy. If someone gets
something easily, the value is less. If
someone gets something with difficulty,
so then
we had interviews. And in the
interviews, we grilled the people.
And those who survived the grilling
or passed the grilling,
in grilling only they come to know what
is
Your grilling wasn't done by me, it was
done by brother Kaleem.
Allah mashallah, save you.
Previous session, I should take the
grilling myself.
And then the main thing is the
interview. Even in the school, we'll
come to it later on, that if you are
able to judge in the interview well,
then half your
task is done.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allah.